i'd already been kind of brought up on
that side of the family with the crimes
that they were doing my mom was you know
drug trafficking the pimp stuff uh
illegally mining coal
um charity fraud illegally mining yeah
wildcatting coal so you um can you
explain that yes so
to to properly mine coal you have to get
a permit all right
eastern kentucky a lot of people don't
they can't afford the permits you know
they can they can get them a piece of
equipment you know you get a dozen
loader or whatever you're gonna get or
an auger or what have you
so you start mining but you don't get
the permit so you don't have to find do
the you don't have to pay back then it
was like thirty five hundred dollars for
a two acre per minute or five thousand
dollars for a two acre minute let you
strip mine the the coal on that then you
have to pay for the reclamation on top
of that so once you uncover the pit take
the coal out you have to cover back up
the pit
sow grass make sure everything is
environmentally friendly you got a silt
pond everything else at that point so
the whole idea is you buy an acre of
land or some area of land and then you
can there's a whole process you're
supposed to go through the entire
process how many people are involved in
a mining the smallest number of people
required for mining operation you can do
it with three or four people
okay so you've got your loader operator
you've got your dozer operator you need
uh you can you can farm out the trucking
to someone if you need another trucking
company if you need to do that um then
you've got your whoever owns the
business as well so very few people can
run an operation like that and profit
fairly well as long as
you don't have to do the reclamation
all that crap on top of it all right the
reclamation gets pretty expensive so if
you're uncovering a pit of coal
you know a pit so a ton of coal is
basically about 36 cubic inches that's
what what two thousand pounds of coal
weighs if you're in eastern kentucky
because it's that the weight of the
bituminous coal and everything the fact
that you know this is
awesome the fact that you know
exactly
the volume of a ton of coal i mean
yeah you learn this [ __ ] right you
rattle this [ __ ] off so uh so you
uncover the pit and you've got to sell
the pit well the thing is is that where
are you going to sell the coal well you
sell it to one of these other coal
tipples that knows that they're buying
the [ __ ] illegally so back then a ton of
coal was uh they'd give you like 36
bucks per ton is what that is and you'd
have to go out and you'd test the btus
on it you take a sample to the lab test
the btus you take that into the computer
uh british thermal unit
so you'd test how what the btu on the
coal was how about here the coal how
pure the coal is what what what btu it
burns at back then a good a good btu was
around twelve nine was what you'd get
all right so twelve nine coal 36 dollars
a ton you'd take that sample over to the
into the cold tipple they'd say okay
we'll buy this for you how many trucks
you got or how many tons you got and you
say this is what was what we've got then
you'd hire the trucking company and
where you get it out because you know
you've got the agents that are that are
looking for you by this point because
the people that you know you've you've
bought the rights to whoever the
landowner is you said you're going to
give them you know two dollars a ton or
whatever this is
well the other people there are you
paying them off
or are you not well if you're not paying
them off guess what they know your ass
is mining it illegally they're going to
report you well all of a sudden you've
got all these inspectors that are coming
around and everything and hey we know
what you're doing so they're looking for
you to get the pit out so when do you
get the pit out right in the dead of
night so you know you're loading it up
two o'clock in the morning hauling this
ass out is what you're doing you sell it
out from there so um and your mom ran
operations like this
yeah and you said you worked the mine
too yeah you were younger learned how to
run a loader run a dozer learn how to
clean off a pit
everything like that
so this is this is the lifestyle you you
grow up in you know you learn how to do
this stuff
you